good afternoon I am delighted to be here
at Hillsdale uh my topic today is James
Buchanan and public Choice James
Buchanan was awarded the Nobel prize in
economics in
1986 for his contributions to the
development of public
Choice public choice is a research
program that uses economic methods to
analyze political
decisionmaking many scholars have
contributed to that research program but
there is little doubt that Buchanan was
the entrepreneur who established public
Choice as a distinct area of academic
inquiry panana was motivated to
understand how the political process
actually worked rather than how in
theory it might ideally
work first uh he held strong classical
uh uh political uh strong classical
liberal political views and he was was
not timid about acknowledging
them also he was motivated to not only
understand the Machinery of government
but to try to find ways to improve
it to see the transformative impact of
Buchanan's work in public Choice
consider the way that economists treated
activities of government when he started
his
career Buchanan earned his PhD in
economics at the University of Chicago
in
1948 economic theory had become
increasingly mathematical and economists
had derived mathematical conditions that
depicted ideally effic the ideally
efficient allocation of
resources along with mathematical
representations of reasons why these
theoretically ideal conditions would not
be met in real world market
economies if an economy fell short of
that theoretical ideal economists
labeled that a market failure
and argued that government should step
in to correct those
failures the problem with this
methodology banan pointed out is that it
compares the imperfections of a real
world economy with a theoretical
theoretically ideal depiction of
government a depiction of government
that never could occur in
practice the proper approach to public
policy is to apply the same tools
economists use to understand Market
phenomena to understand how government
actually works this is the public Choice
approach just because markets fail to
reach some theoretical ideal does not
mean that government can do any better
using parallel language governments can
also fail to reach that theoretical
ideal although buchana was a
self-proclaimed classical liberal he saw
the necessity of government to preserve
an orderly and productive Society
Buchanan said and I'm quoting the
anarchist Utopia must be acknowledged to
hold a lingering if ultimately spous
attractiveness little more than casual
reflection is required however to
suggest that the whole idea is a
conceptual
Mirage the title of his book the limits
of Liberty between Anarchy and
Leviathan
which which I'm hoping is going to pop
up on a slide uh oh there we go it just
took me a while to figure out how that
works uh the title of his
book the limits of Liberty between
Anarchy and Leviathan is a good summary
of Buchanan's views on the role of
government the limits of Liberty lie
between Anarchy and
Leviathan
uh in Anarchy life would be in the words
of Thomas Hobbs a war of all against all
the Constitutional challenge is to
design a government strong enough to
protect people's rights but constrained
to prevent them from becoming a
leviathan that violates people's
rights Buchanan envisioned a government
as a mechanism that ideally enabled
people to accomplish collectively ends
that they could not accomplish
individually in the calculus of consent
co-author with Gordon tullk they say and
I'm quoting
again there we
go Collective action is viewed as the
action of individuals when they choose
to accomplish their purposes
collectively rather than individually
government is seen as nothing more than
the set of processes the machine which
allows such Collective action to take
place Buchanan thought that the United
States government did a tolerably good
job of living up to this idea deal
although throughout his career he became
increasingly dissatisfied with the
direction in which American society and
American government was
headed throughout his career buchanana
was interested in designing
constitutional constraints on the powers
of government so that government would
live up to that ideal of protecting
individual rights while being
constrained from violating those rights
the test as to whether govern govern
rules lived up to that ideal was whether
those who were subject to them agreed
with with them those who were subject to
the rules agreed with those
rules that meant Buchanan emphasized
that everyone agreed with the rules not
just a majority while it is unrealistic
to think that in a large Society
everyone could come to an agreement on
the rules a part of Buchanan's research
program was considering conditions under
which hypothetical agreement could be
reached on the rules under which
government operated this focus on the
rules to constrain government power
remained a central focus of Buchanan's
work throughout his
career the publication of Buchanan
andell's calculus of consent in
1962 might be viewed as the beginning of
public Choice as a clearly identifiable
research program in
1963 the year after the calculus of
consent was published Buchanan and tullk
hosted a conference at the University of
Virginia to gather like-minded Scholars
which evolved into the annual meeting of
the public Choice
society that initial meeting also
produced a volume papers and non-market
decisionmaking which was edited by
Gordon tulk and evolved into the journal
public
choice in
1969 Buchanan and TK along with former
Buchanan student Charles getts relocated
to Virginia Tech and established the
center for study of public Choice While
others had used the tools of Economics
to analyze political processes
previously Buchanan's entrepreneurship
established public Choice as a well
recognized research
program in his early days through the
1960s and into the
1970s public Choice focused on
collective decision decision making
procedures voting in particular and on
ways in which governments could be con
constrained to act in the interest of
those who are governed as the research
program blossomed and more
Scholars uh were interested in applying
economic methods to study political
decisionmaking public Choice focused
increasingly on government failure
reasons why government actions tended to
lead to inefficient
outcomes one problem with Democratic
political institutions is that
concentrated interests tend to have a
disproportionate influence over public
policy they are able to lobby for
legislation that benefits themselves at
the expense of the general public it is
easier to organize a small group than a
large one and concentrated benefits give
them an incentive to organize whereas
disperse costs lessen the incentive for
those who pay the costs to
organize say an interest group of 25
firms uh proposes a program that will
transfer $25 million to them by imposing
a cost on 25 million
citizens each member of the interest
group would stand to gain $1
million giving them a big incentive to
lobby for that program each citizen
would bear the cost cost of $1 providing
little incentive for citizens to act in
opposition to the program this example
shows why the political system tends to
produce public policies that benefit
concentrated interests by imposing costs
on members of the general public uh and
I might interject here in thinking about
this that uh sometimes one of the
problems people perceive with democracy
Democratic decision is the tyranny of
the majority right the the problem that
majorities can impose costs on
minorities but here we're being like a
little more pessimistic than that it's
really a tyranny of minorities it's
minorities that are able to organize to
impose costs on the
majority regulatory capture is another
problem that arises in government
regulatory agencies nominally are
created to constrain regul ated firms
and benefit the general public but over
time those agencies tend to further the
interests of firms they
regulate the general public has little
interest and typically little knowledge
about the regulatory activities of
government regulated firms are
knowledgeable and have an incentive to
Lobby government Regulators this tilts
the regulatory balance of power such the
government regulations tend to favor the
concentrated interests of firms they
regulate rather than the dispersed
interests of the general
public and I might Al I'll also
interject here the notice the language
I'm using I'm talking about concentrated
interests and dispersed interests
sometimes people talk about special
interests but there no interests are
more special than others everybody has
interests the people who are able to
work to to uh accomplish those interests
further those interests are concentrated
interests who can organize so rather
than thinking about special interests
I'd rather that we think about organized
interests and unorganized
interests one important lesson of public
choice is that while interest group
politics and Regulatory capture result
in inefficient policies they produce
only minimal net benefits for those uh
interest groups grou competition among
interest groups for interest group
benefits expends real resources that
dissipate the value of the benefit to
the interest group that competition for
government benefits goes by the name of
rent
seeking as Gordon tullk pointed
out interest group benefits do not just
appear on their own they are proposed by
interest groups that benefit and those
interest hire lobbyists and attorneys
they establish offices in capitals and
engage in those lobbying activities and
those activities use up real resources
they add nothing to economic output but
they use real resources rent Seekers
should be willing to pay up to the value
of those rents uh that they are seeking
to get the
rents assume to take simple numbers here
assume a that uh a prot itive tariff on
foreign competitors could produce a
profit of $100 for a firm or assume that
a firm could profit by $100 if a
regulation were passed to create a
barrier to entry for competitors to give
that firm some Monopoly
power they would be willing to expend up
to
$99 to get that $100 benefit and we'd be
better off by
$1 but the resources The Firm uses at
$99 in resource The Firm uses to get
those benefits those resources are
wasted they are a welfare cost that
results from rent seeking inefficient
public policies cost more than they
first appear because of those
rent-seeking
losses another mode of government
failure is that the incentives facing
government bureaucracies lead them to be
inefficient unlike private firms which
have an incentive to maximize profit by
creating value for their customers
bureaucracies have incentives to
maximize their budgets and perpetuate
their
missions bureaucrats like people in
general have an incentive to look out
for their own well-being a growing
budget for their agencies can give them
more job security and a route toward
promotions and pay increases they may
have interest Beyond monetary
compensation they may seek power they
may be after Prestige but all these
goals too can be furthered by enlarging
their budgets in the same way that
economists characterize firms as profit
maximizers public Choice has
characterized government bureaucracies
as budget
maximizers
meanwhile government agencies have no
incentive to actually solve the problems
they were created to address if they did
solve them there would be no longer a
need for the agency and its employees
would lose their jobs and that's
something to consider you know in the
private sector if a firm uh is
unsuccessful in uh in its Endeavors it
goes out of business uh in the public
sector government bureaucracies if they
fail to achieve their goals they get a
larger budget so they can try harder
next time
so public Choice has developed a
substantial body of analysis describing
why government programs are likely to
produce less than optimal outcomes in
response to the m mainstream economic
analysis that concludes that markets are
not perfect so governments should
intervene public Choice analysis has
shown that governments are also
imperfect and that government
intervention is likely to decrease
welfare a romantic notion of democracy
depicts democratic governments as
accountable to their citizens and acting
to further their
interests a realistic view of the
incentives facing citizens and voters
call this romantic notion of democracy
into question the problem is that
individuals citizens and voters have no
influence over their governments as
individuals while it is true that the
votes all aggregated together determine
who will hold political power no one
individual vote will have any effect on
an election
outcome voting is a purely expressive
Act